good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it is the Monday after
Thanksgiving I am feeling full I'm
excited to be back we missed you all we
very much enjoyed our vacation we really
did recharged I'm like Ramona season 3
real houses in New York I'm renewed
you're a renewed woman I'm a renewed
woman totally I think the Monday after
Thanksgiving is probably one of the
worst days it's the Mondays Monday ever
no not to sound like someone who like
works for bustle but it's the Monday is
Monday ever it really is but we're here
to make it a little better for you guys
and you know what as much as like waking
up this morning was so hard pure torture
I am really happy to be here and nothing
gets me going like saying good morning
Millennials nothing gets me going if
you're also feeling really tired just
look in the mirror and say to yourself
hands on your hips power stance power
stance good morning Millennials also
here's a little pro tip that we learned
while on break this week if you're doing
on vacation do yourself a favor and come
back the day before your chance to come
back like so obviously everyone probably
came back from their travels on Sunday
we came back Saturday the Utah airport
was bustling bustling metropolis we got
back late late Saturday night I fell
asleep yesterday like having the day to
shower we blow out my hair
unpack see Ben's parents like I really
feel like yesterday was one of the most
fulfilling days of my life like I woke
up feeling this morning like okay I
don't want to but I can take on the week
understood well actually I mean I'm so
glad I had yesterday because I needed it
but I didn't it was not like fulfilling
or productive whatsoever I literally
watched all the television that I needed
to watch I call Real Housewives and it's
so it's so annoying I'm not gonna say
hard cuz it's not hard but it's annoying
to watch like one episode agree with
everything it's like I just by the time
the 40 minutes are up I just got into it
especially to a new set of women
especially with a franchise like OC
that's already pretty dead it's like
only by the end of the episode when
they're fighting at the bar this week
was I really like okay I need another
episode so I talked about Dallas only by
the dinner oh I didn't get there anyone
show I didn't you thought what's up this
week that was that was the week that we
missed
but you had seen it oh my god [ __ ]
hilarious but also kind of means
mean I was completely like I was I was
appalled by the way I was appalled and
also really shook at Brandis just like
randomly sticking up early and that's
how you know like she felt really
strongly no and the way that I felt was
exactly how Brandi felt like I preferred
DeAndre and Kerri right now but they're
completely wrong and it's not it was
making me uncomfortable with how mean it
was like honestly when they came out and
then when they came out in it it could
have been like a harmless joke that was
like a little mean but they wouldn't
stop badgering it was so hard to put on
I couldn't figure it out it needs
instructions shut up
it was so uncomfortable so rude and
Cameron was cracking me up the whole
episode like she's becoming a favorite
of mine yeah anyways we have so much to
discuss and I'm so glad while we were in
Utah we did to Pete Ryan episodes really
that was the slow four stories which we
were like the stories that we're
sweeping the nation while we were gone
I'm so glad we spoke about them because
now we don't have to talk about last
week's Dancing with the Stars really
AMAs right that was so long ago we
recaps it all on the patrons if you want
to hear about AMAs Justin Timberlake
being a freak
what else did we talk about sassy baby
yes which is something that will
definitely come up again because I'm
obsessed I'm obsessed me too and we're
very much ship it so head over to
patreon.com/scishow morning shows to
check out those two episodes we have
five more this month they will most
likely be at the beginning of the month
because we are both traveling at the end
of the month yes for a little neat what
he's doing for New Year's I don't know
we don't plans yet so you know I was
thinking last night me and Ben are gonna
be in the Hamas with Ben's parents like
leading up to New Year's we're gonna
come back a few days before but I think
Ben actually might go to Miami like
straight from the Bahamas for like three
days for New Year's maybe that could
work for me yeah I think I hate Miami
and watching I don't see this week I was
like even more sure that I hate it um I
don't like live for Miami either and I
haven't been back since two years
actually we went for Olivia's
bachelorette party but I haven't like
chosen to go back since two years ago me
and Ben went for like the December
winter break and we took such a long
[ __ ] trip we were there for three
weeks by the time it was New Year's I
was ready to get the [ __ ] out literally
we had like I now look back on that trip
with such distaste because I had such a
poor time and then the time before that
I was there on a girls trip where like
friendships ended like there were there
was a girl there like it wasn't even
like a dramatic trip like you really see
people when you travel like that like I
move the litter haven't spoken to this
girl like since it was just such a it
was a tough trip so my name is just like
kind of a toxic place but for New Year's
I do feel as though like in and out
toxic holiday right three days in and
out like I think it actually might be
less okay that actually does work for my
schedule so maybe we can start to put it
because it's so weird this is an
interesting stretch of time because the
way I feel today it's like I feel like
it's January 1st 2020 you know we just
came off of a long break but now we have
like these next like 28 days to just
reflect on the year you know and you're
right it does feel it cuz you know in
the car this morning everybody thought
of my new year's resolution I was gonna
like stayin on the show today but it's
not chatting right first but maybe able
to share it anyway cuz I feel like
actually it's a good resolution for
people to think about I feel like and
you know what I don't really feel like I
was this type of person up until the
last year we're like I talk about like
how fat I am like all the time like in a
serious way like I joke like I'm chubby
like that's fine
look I really talk about like my weight
so much and honestly I feel like it's
contributing to my bad wait do you I
mean look if I just stop talking about
it like in something about it so much I
really do want to stop talking about it
like AI think it's like not interesting
like on the show you know like no one
wants to hear about like how about I am
and to look I think it's bad for my
mental health I'm going to stop talking
about it I'm not sure what examples
you're providing so I feel like every
time you talk about it it's funny and
someone who like it lives in a world
that's only about weight like I don't
mind but maybe other people do yeah I
just for myself I don't like it also for
the show I don't think like people want
to hear about that so I think it'd be
good business
that's an interesting resolution well
yeah 2080 is to think of like everything
you want to resolve such a crazy 28 days
I'm gonna be in Canada this week and
tarry town which is Westchester
obviously New York this weekend so
tickets available no job com
Tarrytown is sold out sorry you can't
come you can come to Casino Rama in
Orillia Ontario today I get tickets a
girl's mother come I'll be there on
Friday night so exciting so many
housekeeping updates I'm just gonna run
through that but right now our Black
Friday Cyber Monday sale is still on
it's on until midnight tonight 15% off
apparel 20% off accessories get what you
want because most of that stuff on the
site is not being restocked this is our
only sale we don't do sales because our
prices are so goddamn low uh exactly but
like all the stuff that's there right
now pretty much doesn't being restocked
so if you want it get it now because we
have our holiday merge dropping on
Friday it is this right are you December
6 it is you've seen some teasers from
our trip to Utah we're gonna be posting
more throughout the week you guys it's
the stuff we have holiday sweaters
we have robes we have slippers we don't
have slippers have onesies onesies
we have vintage merch coming back
some of your favorites if you weren't a
toaster than in your toaster now it's
all gonna be there for you
so gird your loins Friday 1:00 p.m.
Eastern Time
we made it we tried to ease up on you
Pacific coasters yeah by the way after
living for a week on Mountain Time which
is two hours behind you soon time I'm
here to tell you justice for people who
live in mountain in Pacific time it
[ __ ] sucks I don't know how you don't
get things we're in for you like the
fact that live TV airs not live one hour
late like makes no goddamn sense it's
torture and I'm sorry I'm really sorry
for you also I've been weirdly
jet-lagged from this to Albert I'm
change it's like we go to LA and I don't
feel a thing this this two hours has
changed me okay so me and Ben not to be
like a total name-dropper me and then
like a few months ago I went to dinner
with Jonathan Cheban and he was talking
about it he's so jet-lagged from LA and
me and Ben were like making fun of him
we're like Kimmy jet lag from really
like it's not Europe I take it back
I'm fully jet-lagged for a mountain time
it's insane yesterday I woke up at 2:40
p.m. I woke up at 1:00 p.m. it was crazy
like and I was a little disappointed cuz
sunday was supposed to be my day of
fulfill its fulness yeah and I already
lost a few hours but it was still a good
day I was just glad I slept late because
it's time that I'm not eating which is a
huge accomplishment these days you guys
we ate so much in Utah like a driven sob
I have absolutely no regrets I have no
regrets I woke up every day and made
myself kraft mac and cheese
it's just so important to live that way
sometimes but then you have to come back
and and get healthy
another housekeeping announcement I'm
sure everyone is just like dying to see
I put up on my IG TV I make up something
and I saw the internet is abuzz you want
to know why because I went back and
watched the first and only YouTube video
I ever put up of my everyday makeup
routine which is when I was living like
in my old apartment my makeup routine is
so different I used to NYX foundation
like I don't know who the [ __ ] I thought
I was it's such an embarrassment that
like that can't be the most recent up
like most up-to-date makeup tutorial for
me I won't allow it
so IG TV is actually a really happy
medium because I was not putting
together like my camera to go on YouTube
use my phone I just sort of tripod for
my mirror and I think it turned out
pretty good and you know after watching
it I've only watched it I'm seventy five
thousand times I'm really here this 75
yeah use i am so certain that like my
makeup routine is [ __ ] snatch
honestly like i was doing the tutorial
and i was like damn I look stunning
do you want to know how your makeup
routine is snatched and now
I seen this about myself it's the fact
that like I went out maybe two years ago
and it's really the same sing oh maybe I
switch up a few products but like the
way that I sprained my face hasn't
changed so it's just like a classic look
oh that's interesting mine was
completely different I used one product
the same it was this mascara like I
literally did not use any of the same
products brushes blenders like nothing
that's so crazy
it was crazy I accept to go makeup
shopping because I dropped my bronzer
and you tide and tell anyone anyone
upset anyone but I dropped it and I have
no more bronzer which bronzer do you use
I actually use a contour NARS palette
Paloma Loma yeah stinks I like it that's
good I mean make it some animal it's
just clay they test on animals it's clay
that they test some animals stop no it's
terrible
that's so hurtful they tested up do
Jackie ah ok I'm not gonna read didn't
Newgrounds r8 cosmetics is great they
make great bronzer yeah ok well anyway
speaking of makeup tutorials that's a
great segue into our first story so
without further ado it is time for the
past 5 stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast you know that puts
me in a tough spot Jackie because it's
definitely time and I don't want to like
step on your toes and you don't want to
step on my Segway I'm sure I don't want
to separate your segue but I'm going to
because I would be mmm
what's the condition ah yes RDH remissed
devastate oh and heartbroken Rio box it
up rusty we are so much tea deficits are
so much teeny to talk about we have to
recap somebody shows at the end of this
episode
but the winner of 16 Emmys and three
Golden Globes the Amazon original the
marvelous miss nasal is returning for an
eagerly awaited new season on December 6
that's Friday
haled is one of the best shows on the
small screen of any genre by deadline
this season takes Minchin Suzy on a
comedy tour through the US with stops in
Miami Las Vegas la filled with original
music sweeping dance numbers and museum
worthy costumes and some of the most
lush production design on TV honestly
sounds like the dirty jeans story you
know hitting up Miami Las Vegas in LA
I'm still like 100 percent sure of the
Marvis miss Mazal is loosely based on my
life and while I haven't gotten any
proper credit I'm still happy for them
in their success because that means you
know my story is relatable or maybe your
life is loosely based on her I don't
think so the serious award-winning cast
includes Rachel Brosnahan Alex
Borenstein who as you know is a Steve
brown-noser with a hidden [ __ ] agenda
angermaier tony shalhoub jane lynch the
hardest working woman in hollywood and
more alongside new and notable guest
stars like sterling kate brown its 1960
man time to see why this beloved series
is a modern marvel watch the new season
of the marvelous mrs. Mazal December 6
only on Amazon Prime video I love it I'm
so excited for the new season because
the style is straight styling up wild in
living it up in the city update NARS
does not have Sun animals are you sure
positive people ready in the comments
and I googled it and it's true ok
thought Sephora customer service says
Arthur size does not test on animals
take it back I'm sorry thank God really
wanting to get it again ok first story
back to makeup tutorials
back to YouTube Olivia Jade I was 8 her
returns literally going to ask you right
now if Olivia Jim is a story of course
that was my segue I was absolutely
shocked when I saw her Instagram I woke
up to a group chat cuz I woke up at 3
o'clock mom and the video had been up
she posted a two-minute video basically
saying that she's coming back to YouTube
she's really missed it she cannot speak
on anything that's going on legally
which we already knew but that she feels
like a part of her is missing therefore
she's gonna come back to YouTube even
though she can't talk about what's going
on and honestly I don't know if this is
like the popular opinion but I'm here
for it no I know and you know what I was
reading
I wanted to see like I someone I don't
know if our opinion on her is skewed
because we just liked her or because we
know what it's like to be canceled and I
think now anytime someone's cancelled
like we always fight for the underdog
like Kevin Hart like we always just take
that side because nobody does right and
having been in that position like it's
not always what people think it is
people think they know everything about
Lori Loughlin and Olivia Jade but they
[ __ ] don't so I definitely think our
opinion is not the popular one but I was
in Olivia Jade sand before all this
happened we watched her videos like we
just literally put them that's what made
you change your makeup tutorial from
using in my ex honey yes and then you
thought for a while that you didn't have
to wear foundation because you were
watching like a 15 year old do her
makeup it's true so while I know it's
not the popular opinion and I was
reading comments and people are [ __ ]
evil like saying such horrible things on
YouTube Twitter she doesn't have
Instagram comments able she doesn't she
hasn't disabled unless I have the
ability to comment on
yeah shouts grunge and Kwan's yeah we're
friends like I we partied it up in
Mexico I she's mr. no I wish oh my god
but when I met her she was like such a
nice girl her sister so cute like good
steamy vibes mm-hmm and honestly their
mom was kind of strict so I was like you
know I was just like shocked you know
but the video it was a little sad like
and I know people are having like such a
hard time feeling bad for cuz like she's
rich and like apparently that means
you're immune to like feelings
yeah hurt so if I hit Kara she's rich I
was reading the comments in the morning
Tube Facebook group because people are
so conflicted like I live a Stan and
like they they believe her and they
believe in her or they just like [ __ ]
hate her so much and like people were
just like making arguments that were
just so devoid of like empathy it's like
well she's rich she's gonna be fine like
no no you can still be affected by
things and be rich like right doesn't
one is not indicative of the other and I
just thought people were being like
really harsh on her I'm really I think
it's great she came back to YouTube but
she'll start changing the narrative
around what people talk about her
obvious that this is gonna follow her
around for the rest of her life so she
might as well like to start you know
getting back to her passion projects
like if someone told me I couldn't work
on the TNN Instagram like I would be
devastated right and it's like the fact
that she does have money makes it even
like cuter that she just wants to come
back and like do her hobby and her
passion project right she doesn't need
the money right um the only place I read
comments were in the morning toasters
and the morning Tube and I feel like
there was a lot of mixed opinions and
there were a lot of people who you know
will never didn't like her before and
still don't like her and there are
people who liked her and are excited
that she's back it's been almost nine
months and I think it's time like and if
she ever planned on coming back to
YouTube like the sooner the better and
she can't talk about it she won't be
able to talk about it until the trial is
over which can take a really long time
it's gonna be she's better off start
like coming back now before every before
like the trial that's really heated and
yeah she wouldn't be able to come on
without saying anything right now it's
kind of in a lull while we wait to see
like what happens so I'm I I'm good with
it yeah I saw a lot of cons people being
like she's reading from a script' I
didn't think it was scripted I know I
should've been a little more scripted
honestly but I think the fact that it
wasn't like makes it more genuine and
honestly I wasn't I never had watched
her videos until all of this happened
and then like when we were talking about
her every day I was like let me see what
she's about and I loved her content so
I'm happy that she's coming back
the people who were fans of her most of
them will remain fans and that's all she
really needs yeah
and she's doing it because she enjoys it
right there's good motives behind it and
if you don't like it and you don't want
to support it you don't have to watch it
right that and that a wonderful thing
about the Internet where you can just
like minimize and turn it off you don't
have to release the public's press
release that you're gonna unfollow
someone like you could just stop
watching their videos you guys it's it's
really simple it's as simple as that so
I'm excited for her video I'm excited
for you in the snitch who loved her and
it's like I wonder she looked a little
different in the video like what new
makeup is she doing looked like she had
like lost some weight like not
intentionally you know what I mean like
I think it actually it's been difficult
on her I'm sure it has been but that
reminded me except like I was saying I
just like live for new YouTube content
and honestly Jeffrey star does not
release videos at a frequency that I'm
comfortable with because once a week is
like what am I supposed to do the other
six years he releases them once a week
hmm we watched the Jacqueline Hill what
is review review on our trip and it was
just so good I need tonight a big screen
I know it actually looks really good
such a basic [ __ ] I still use champagne
pop by the way that's why she's doing
highlighter she's very credible in the
highlighter community I trust her
yeah but that reminded me um it's just
so funny how like Stan hood like changes
over time because last night I watched a
new James Charles video he did with
ketchup because she's really singing uh
makeup line called Kesha rose and it was
just so weird like I was watching and
it's either I don't know what if it has
to do with like my rising Stan Hood for
Jeffrey or just like you know styles
changed like I'm so over James Charles
like and I used to be a Stan like I
bought it's [ __ ] merch like I don't
know I'm just like I'm so uninspired by
him now and I don't know whether it has
to do with like the Tati takedown
because honestly I was on his side and
that yeah we're just like now on my
passion and energy is like directed
towards Jeffrey star but like I was just
like so over James's content I feel like
his last few videos had been like so
uninspired like and he's just like not I
don't know I just don't relate to him
anymore
I think that's really natural feeling
but it just thing makes me sad and
scared because it's like is that how
people feel about us oh you know it's
like they did not think like there's
nothing that happened and I just like
I'm genuinely over it oh my god I
[ __ ] hope not
so uh I I never really watched his
videos before I'm just like here for him
doing his thing you know
ya know like live your life I just feel
like I'm not gonna be a part of it
anymore or at least for a while
I know and not in the bad way I just
like styles change yeah they feel like
Jeffrey is much more like my aesthetic
like rich you know yeah I hear that
also I just got my order from the shane
dawson like i ordered it oh and a
regular person sorry i'm not on the
peerless apparently oh yeah i am i
thought it was like interesting to see
that i just got it like to date well I
just got my packages when did you place
the order I placed it the day that it
launched
so it took November first yeah but
things weren't so bad I've dated me
along the way that it's gonna take a
while and they gave me the option to
cancel my order if I didn't have the
patience to wait as people who run like
an online store I have the utmost
respect for people with like good
customer service and I even I saw so
many people complaining oh and I don't
know if we ever recap the final we
didn't we didn't I cuz I just watched it
I thought that the final episode of
Shane Dawson conspiracy palette series
was really interesting and I don't think
they meant to do this but I feel like it
was really telling of how like toxic
Stan culture can be like when they were
cutting clips of all the people who like
didn't get product literally like
getting angry it's like are you kidding
like you're angry at someone because you
didn't get what you want like it shows
how like that love can really very
quickly turn into a hatred I'm a troll
the people weren't becoming like haters
and trolls but it's just like this
entitlement yeah it's like if you know
if H&M released a shirt and you didn't
get it are you gonna start hating H&M
feeling like you should have like I just
thought the way some people were talking
in those clips that they were clipping
it I don't even think they meant to
highlight this was like so [ __ ] nasty
and like entitled and it really shows
how like toxic SAN culture can be
because like I'm like oh [ __ ] do you
think why do you deserve it like it was
just so like insightful in a way yeah it
was interesting I also really liked how
they ended it it's like so genius
because now everyone's gonna buy another
mini conspiracy for this one shape Brian
um I won't be one of them I'm so hurt I
don't even know anymore like I just keep
buying all this crap I don't even wear
but now I'm really sure I actually I'm
trying to get better in my eyeshadow so
maybe I do need the new conspiracy
palette I think you do I think so too
anyways I got my mini controversy so
excited to try it out ya know it's just
like it's we come full circle like we
watch the series we got some products or
like I can I'm like
I can put this series to bed like I feel
good about it yeah and it honestly is
like an iconic thing not happening you
know what's so crazy about it and
jeffree star summed it up so perfectly
like this was the biggest day in Shopify
sales history like they sure they broke
a million websites and Geoffrey was like
why are we on the view
like why is like no one is talking about
it I actually read what Geoffrey might
get asked to do a lot of press but he
doesn't need to know like aside from
watching it and it being like our
Facebook groups and stuff it's like the
New York Times isn't writing about it
but it's the biggest thing that's the
biggest makeup launch ever the only
place that I read about it was in
BuzzFeed they did like a recap of the
series and of course like they focused
on Jeffrey's cancellation like are you
kidding you know and like they just had
to like mention it all and that's why he
doesn't go and do press right are you
know I don't think like he should be on
the view like they asked him and it's
like he should be what everybody is
talking about he should be on the cover
of The Wall Street Journal a cover of
Forbes I wonder if he is a publicist I
don't know but like I'm pretty sure that
because they don't talk like buta Singh
talked about Jeffrey starchiness and so
whether they have him on right but they
should be the ones you have on the toast
hundred we talk about it a hundred
percent I think we should fly to LA I
don't have a suit from Calabasas I would
absolutely love to oh my god I think
like now when we talk about dream guest
stars obviously like Kim Kelly Clarkson
I think Jeffrey is now up there 1,000
bucks not only am i so and when I was
doing my YouTube video my YouTube my IG
TV makeup tutorial last night I was
really realizing like how not only my
makeup has changed so much into watching
Jeffery but I think my outlook on makeup
has watched has changed so much like I
like live for makeup like and I just
used to find it like dreadful to like
every morning like wake up now I like
can't wait to highlight my face like
it's the most exciting part of my day
yeah and I think something that he does
that makes it so great for his business
it's like he talks about how the makeup
is supposed to be fun and you should be
trying new things and experimenting so
like you don't just need to buy stuff
for your everyday routine like the way
that I approach makeup it's like oh if
I'm not gonna wear that lipstick every
day like I don't need it yep and then I
still buy it but no it's like you don't
have to commit to wearing it every day
in order to buying it he's a great
salesman no he it's so crazy how many
products I bought just because he like
likes them do you know what I mean yeah
like the Jeffrey's our stamp of approval
like holds a lot away yeah when I'm like
oh I need a new like translucent powder
like what's the best on the market like
what is Jeffrey like except
I did buy the Dior air flash foundation
like it's like that looks like spray
paint yeah and I wore it the first night
in Morocco and in every picture I looked
like a ghost was it too much coverage no
it was just like it had like a
reflective quality to it that was like a
flashback II and it looks really good on
she oh yes it looks really good in
person and I kept taking pictures I'll
show you I was like who is the clown
buddy I'm not between that and like my
yellow dress I was like looking nuts but
it was like I was really feeling my look
that night you should try this in our
foundation that I love they don't have
some animals I know but I just don't
live for NARS for some reason I feel
like all our products that don't work oh
I think the opposite ideally no frills
everything works like their concealer
it's the best concealer I do use the
concealer I apologize it is fantastic
that unshaped tape by Tarte are two of
the best concealers yeah so I really
feel like I'm wanting to turn the girls
on a job into a beauty paycheck I'm
feeling so inspired I'm telling you
Jeffery stars like so in my bands you
should start a beauty chat like a beauty
page or just me me like my IG TV could
be like all be today because I'm nobody
watches it anyway let me down but if
they want to watch it they can right
yeah but am I gonna like post to my
Instagram like head up my G TV you know
like it's just gonna be there and my
true fans will know okay I think I'm
really excited for you which oh okay
this next story is something that's been
developing while we were gone and it's
really [ __ ] crazy in [ __ ] up what's
going on at America's Got Talent
oh my god I'm very upset about it
because as you know what I know about
the world comes straight from Gabrielle
Union's Twitter like I stand I follow
her on Twitter she is the most like
educated woman in the world and the fact
that she was on America's Got Talent was
perfect like she's talented she
recognized his talent like she was a
bring it on like it was perfect that's
all you need to know and then basically
her Gabrielle Union and Julianne Hough
were choices on America's Got Talent
news came out that they would not be
renewed for the next season then variety
published I guess they wouldn't be were
knew that they got fired
the show is renewed yeah no no that they
used to would it be renewed for the next
season you know they got fired okay
the variety published like a scathing
article about the culture at AGT and how
julianne hough and gabrielle union like
face like the culture was toxic and
there was discrimination and just like
off-color comments and
you know there were rumors that someone
said something racist to Gabrielle Union
yeah and then like every show they would
just like comment on what the girls were
wearing and like how it wasn't good
enough and like it was just really
[ __ ] up and now they're fired that's
crazy
and julianne hough had really sustained
me but I think she works a lot with the
network and so yes I don't so you think
you can dance right so her statement was
just like looking forward to good
relations with the network yeah and then
Simon Cowell released the statement
Gabrielle Union can't be bought right
because Simon Cowell's production
company released a statement like pretty
much you know sweeping over they said
this is what they said I'll give it to
you straight from the horse's mouth
remain committed to ensuring respectful
workplace for all employees and take
very seriously any questions about
workplace culture we are working with
Miss Union through her representatives
to hear more about her concerns
following which we will take whatever it
next steps may be appropriate so then
Gabrielle Union retweeted a tweet about
how to properly apologize and she wrote
oh my god this this and this by the way
I didn't okay so like I said you'd have
it too and she literally live for her
Twitter and I saw last night that she
retweeted that and obviously you know I
make everything about myself and I was
thinking like okay hold on I'm pulling
it up um
the tweet here it was such a great tweet
yeah it's about and I didn't realize
that yeah I see that she was really like
referring to her situation obviously I
make everything about me I was referring
to my situation like when I apologize
for being canceled I really felt like
here one I sincerely admitted wrongdoing
directly to the offended party I feel
like I really did that too I was twice
as loud and correcting my mistake as you
were in making the mistake like back in
the day like nobody read my tweets and
then like everyone saw my apology like
double V double the eyeballs even triple
layout steps to correct your behavior in
the future that's exactly what I did I
was like really making everything about
myself I was like Tim I feel like I
really did like a good apology
and I realized that it's about something
so much bigger than me you know well you
know what I'm glad that you got
something from it and also like that's
just good for everyone which meeting
ever L you didn't like I stand so hard
so basically that's her statement that
like she thinks this is a half-ass
apology as well it's not an apology they
just said we're gonna look into it
right but it's like no no no Brian
looked into it and it's all there so we
haven't looked into it it's been looked
into so now what
this is so weird also like they go
through talent on America's Got Talent
no but it seems like the only goes
through the female talent because before
this was Mel being Heidi Klum and it's
like why do the male judges who
howie mandel yeah and and sunl and it
was Howard Stern for a while yeah that
was great I'm in his book he said that
was amazing so transformative for him
but likewise Howie Mandel's staple and
Gabrielle Union Julianne Hough or not I
don't want to stray away from this
important topic but I do have to tell
you that I watch an episode of Deal or
No Deal last night which is hosted by
how we grab Dell it's hosted by Megan
Marco I thought yeah it is actually no
it's inspired by Megan Marco and I guess
like in this new age like just having
women holding around sin like holding
briefcases like isn't okay so they still
do it but they like try and make it seem
like women the women are like so much
more and like they put their Instagram
handles and they talk to them like show
come like beyond the beasts yes and then
they also like all the women tear up
when it's like a sad moment it was a
bachelor this guy was like adopted like
his mom was a breast cancer survivor and
then all the women are like like it was
so stupid but I watch the craziest
[ __ ] episode Deal or No Deal is like
a wild show like the format it's so
interesting this guy had two briefcases
left his briefcase and one of the other
briefcases and either had $5 or $750,000
literally he was like I'm gonna keep
mine and he opened it
$5 and he turned down an offer from the
bank for $330,000 like oh he's an idiot
he's an idiot and his whole family was
saying take it take it he was like a
risk-taker lluís and he was like you
know what I'm gonna say like man if I
think by the way that pisode just ends
right after that so it's like $5 goodbye
we were like excuse me like it was so so
crazy what a great show that's so crazy
it was hilarious CNBC is the best
[ __ ] channel uh
yeah it's good seven I watched Shark
Tank last night obviously episode uh no
on ABC oh you know I was over to CNBC
yeah the new episode was holiday-themed
there were some really great products
that of course these sharks do not make
a deal on until the youngest person came
out oh and they made a deal they just
they ate like that's the next variety
article about shark shaking a just is
low-key one of the funniest but also
most truth statements but I was like
just start watching it through that lens
and like last night's episode was so
good and there were so many good
products and there wasn't a very old
person who was being made fun of or a
very young person who was getting a deal
for no reason but it was like no deals
were made except for the young person by
the way um watching TVs through certain
lens this is so fun you know
watching shark tank through the lens
that it's a gesture watching Jimmy
Fallon to the age that he's an alcoholic
like through the lens that he's an
alcoholic it's just it's transformative
it's a good time ya know what else is
transformative having a signature scent
uh it is by the way it's December and
you need to start switching to a pine
bass yeah you're right I honestly I
missed the boat on my maple they said no
it's time for a pine Bay scent did you
know that scent is the most powerful
sense you have a smell can bring on a
flood of memories influence your mood
and of course enhance your natural style
Sanford is a luxury fragrance
subscription service for perfumes and
colognes they have more than 600
designer brands for you to choose from
each month so you basically you go on
they send you the perfect sized perfume
their travel friendly and it's a month's
worth of that fragrance you're getting
such a great price for it for a designer
fragrance it has 120 sprays per bottle
which is a ton if you think about it and
then the next month with the
subscription you can either get a new
fragrance if you like the one you've had
you can just get a new one it's actually
kind of genius yeah you get to try out
all these perfumes without spending the
money and then you have like travel-size
perfume Eddowes because you really need
perfume on you go like oh wait so like
it's nice to have it sitting on your
stand for no one to see no but what are
you two not used well a 90 minute comedy
show and then you have to do with me in
green you best believe you have suffered
you best believe it
plus they're products from other
categories like skincare wellness and
makeup that carry brands like Coke re
which is a favorite here at the morning
toast glam glow tart and so many others
we have a new offer we've had an offer
for a while but a change to make sure
that your you know get to step in with
an exclusive offer just for our
listeners you can get 30% off your first
month today
that's only $10 for your first fragrance
go to scent bird dot-com slash steen use
our code steam for 30% off your first
month
again that's SCE and t-bird comm slash
Steen ste n for you to try your first
perfume or cologne for just $10 sign on
smell amazing
I think love that we've created a brand
where our partners are making links said
bird composting 100% it gives me great
joy to things Michele Beeman says that
Snitch uses her semper to cover up her
cigarette smoke oh so important no one
wants to smell that stink on her and -
it's also a great gift really thought
yes yeah it is so think about that
giving someone like a year subscription
to said bird like you're giving them a
year of joy yeah and a year of like
for you because they'll smelled it and
in the words of gia Giudice its season
of joy Jack - talking about Real
Housewives of New Jersey but without
they're okay because right now we need
to talk about Real Housewives of New
York or Real Housewives of Chicago oh
yeah because Tinsley Mortimer is engaged
to Scott clooth with a big deny those
are Boston huge rock they got to be
clean she's been like kind of quiet
about it like there was a lot of rumors
that she was engaged and then only a few
days later did she confirm with an
Instagram post and now a week later
she's released like a little video that
was so cute actually did bring a small
tear to my eye like I love an engagement
video especially when it's said to a
Christina Perry song a thousand years
like beautiful she's so cute there's
rumors that like in order for her to
like be engaged right now it means that
like she's no longer on the show and
that she quit midseason it seems like
she has moved to Chicago um you know
what I really appreciate her putting
like her love and her relationship about
thirst like that is a very cool thing to
do in the past their relationship has
been rocky because she wouldn't do that
like right the show changed her life in
so many ways like she couldn't imagine
giving it up but when they were
announcing the new Housewives franchise
everyone was around the same time that
it was announced that Tinsley and Scott
we're getting engaged and that she was
leaving and they think I'm to actually
be the perfect segue kind of house
sheena was the segue from Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills into
Vanderpump rules like I do think they
could literally make an episode of
Tinsley leaving the Real Housewives of
New York and starting the Real
Housewives of Chicago they don't I don't
want to lose her I think that they
should have Real Housewives of Chicago
but that's not the way that they should
do it because people don't love Tinsley
enough like I feel like I'm her biggest
fan just compared to the fact that like
no one else is her fan it's it she's
hard to root for because she's so like
pathetic sometimes like she's not let go
an independent woman by any means like
she finds herself by whatever man she's
attached to at the moment and like
honestly as much as people give it to
you like housewives is an empowering
show it's like women doing their own
thing it's like Bethenny said she said
swimming back 100 years but you know
what she's red representing the women
who set women back there's live in a day
and age where she's allowed to do right
like a woman can do whatever she was
including set women back 100 yeah but as
a show that's built for women it is
difficult to watch her sometimes she's
just a different sort of character and I
appreciate I appreciate the difference
that she brings a diversity yeah
I just think doesn't bother me and like
I shouldn't bother me she's very much
like a certain kind of girl and like
they exist and we should see them the
the craziest thing about all this is I
think a lot of people forget is that Cal
rad so I'll set these two you know is
she gonna be at the wedding
totally I'm not going I think that the
weirdest friendship was the friendship
between Tinsley and Carol because it was
so influential in the breakdown of
Cowell force Bethany and then Carol left
and it seems like Tinsley and Carol
didn't stay besties and Tinsley and
Bethany are actually good friends
Bethany tweeted Congrats
Livi's are on good terms see Carol tweet
Congrats I don't know like Carol's
Twitter's like so active like if you
have destroy so far yeah understood well
honestly I'm really happy for her like I
think I mean it's great for her and I
guess it sounds like a good message to
like all those girls out there who likes
think they're gonna wait for a man I
know they're waiting for Prince Charming
might show us sometimes like these
situations like this is the exception
not the rule
no no this is the acceptance I also
think that there was a lot that we
didn't know about between them and if it
really was about the fact like he didn't
want to be on real husbands in New York
he didn't want to be talked about so
therefore she's always gonna be weird
about it
it made it look like the relationship
was more toxic than it was but maybe he
just had like pure intentions I'm not
wanting to be thirsty I know but you
know relationships like that in the
Bravo universe very rarely work out when
one person doesn't want to be on the
show and the other person won't give it
up Stassi Patrick right but it looks
like she's giving it up so good for that
no I mean if you're gonna give up like a
lifetime a career like Fame it's gonna
be for rich man sorry like and that's
enough she's trading one gem for another
now she's get to work yeah I need coupon
queen now but I think she like really
does like being an it girl so she likes
me famous yeah so maybe she'll find a
way to do that without house guys or we
don't even know she's not on how sizing
right we know this is just a rumor
right so we'll see yeah cuz I I hope she
is okay next shocking news relatively
not and live star and Kim Kardashian
Natalie Halcro reveals she's seven
months pregnant by my diamond she was
pregnant when she was here really yeah
they were on less than seven months ago
oh my god
rather so cute like 29 weeks is seven
months that's crazy
I don't get how people hide pregnancies
like that I know I just love a surprise
pregnancy lady too and I love these
surprises at the end of the pregnancy
right and now it's like the only house
two months of content in them to get a
bet that's like skinny confidential I
think will they have like one more month
of her being pregnant yeah when did she
she was five months ago two months ago
yeah that's only two more months but
that's I'm so here for it just a
surprise pregnancy with like a very
beautiful pregnancy announcement photo
she was wearing like a white leotard
snakeskin knee-high boots hoop earrings
like nothing's changed for her better um
did she she in a relationship not that I
know of them we asked her when she was
on the show and she's she's pretty coy
about it I think maybe she's just
private for but she's also a reality
star so it's kind of know it's always
interesting when people whose jobs are
like inherently thirsty like whether
it's influencing or being on reality
show when they keep certain things
private you know yeah but I like I don't
know study mention anywhere of anyone
that she's dating and she's dated people
like on the shows that she's been on but
I'm pretty sure they were just like play
that update yeah we should ah him on to
the wedding maybe I don't know do you
ship um
no honestly I still ship her in her like
first boyfriend from TV I forgot his
name but he was he was why she was on
wags cuz he was an athlete got it and he
was like just so nice to her and her
cousin like he didn't even let the
cousin live with them like it was so
cute so did spit I guess it wasn't the
right really live getting a new Susan I
feel like no I haven't heard anything
but I feel like they're just living the
dream you know they'll Instagram like
once every two weeks and it's like a
paid post they're best friends with cam
and they're Tim is so excited about the
baby right and I like the Bebe's like
maybe is gonna like be married to like
sane oh yeah let's share birthday party
with someone and they can fight about
whether they want organic candy or not
right so I'm really really happy for her
you know that I [ __ ] Stan these two
and I'm excited for mom content from I
wish she would post more to Instagram
because for people who got famous it
like being influencers she literally had
her like 1 million followers party while
she was on wags um I could use some more
content yeah I agree
that's my only um that's my only note ok
this and final story a little business
is but it's interesting business because
it's box-office news because frozen to
has feasted on Thanksgiving records
break I heard about shattering records
so they broke though Thanksgiving
weekend record that was previously held
by Hunger Games hmm but box office
numbers were down from last year overall
for the weekend and experts are saying
it's because of the irishman being
released on Netflix so like you would
just watch it at home I guess I mean we
watch the Irishmen and this was also my
segue for us to give our review on the
Irishman
we watched the Irishman Emma watch Lion
King and we'd like to offer insights on
both I would like to start with a
positive about the Irishman because it
was the one movie the whole trip that we
could all agree that we wanted to see Oh
actually like before we started watching
it I didn't want to watch it but there
was no arguing with sexual Pierrot like
he wanted to watch it's like seven out
of eight of us we're in agreement and
that's big for us because we usually
watch trailers for like 40 minutes and
then we don't even watch a movie and so
the reviews are glowing when I put you
know my honest opinion I'm an Instagram
story people were like how could you say
it's a Z and for sure like don't get me
wrong
amazing cast amazing director amazing
acting amazing but just because good
people are in and worked on it does it
make the movie good like people are so
blinded by Mark the like Martin
Scorsese's the Irish mean like that they
refuse to think that there's anything
wrong with the movie and that's just
like a skewed way of thinking and it's a
dumb way of thinking and whether or not
you live for Martin Scorsese like you
have to admit that the movie was too
long especially for a movie where
nothing actually happened it was just
like I only realized at the end of the
movie that there was no plot in this
movie it's just the the life of someone
yeah well so we won't give too many
spoilers but I actually wish that I knew
this before I watch the movie I read the
description after I watched movie it's
just one line it was like oh yeah that
is what the movie was about I don't know
I was what is it's a life of Rechab a
mobster recounts his life of secrets in
the goofily no crime that is not a plot
right especially for a three-hour movie
it's like so this starts in the
beginning but Donita Nero is old and
he's talking to someone about his life
who's he talking to him at what point
did that part happen why did he decide
to finally tell everything when he was
just like a vault for so many years okay
that's the thing because the whole movie
he's sitting inside the nursing home
talking to someone I thought maybe he
was a reporter I didn't know then
finally we catch up to real life
and now he's sitting outside but the FBI
was he talking to the FBI the whole time
no and you would think he didn't tell
the FBI anything because like he would
never but he's telling someone something
at some point why and when did he decide
to tell no incredibly stupid the Anna
Paquin of it all we we literally watched
I think it's like a three-hour movie we
watched for two hours and we had to
break for dinner and it was like when is
the movie gonna start like when are we
gonna know what weren't like invested in
no and then there is a climax of the
movie you know that thing happens where
he takes the plane and he goes but when
that's happening I'm like oh we've been
watching two hours for this and it was
so anticlimactic he just like did the
thing and then I'm like is this what the
movie is about yeah and it's just like
from the man who gave us shutter island'
like the inaugural toast movie of the
week I expected more and because the
real problem with it was the story this
the way that the story was told in the
movie the direction was slow problem
linked danira was incredible I loved the
cast I loved Joe Pesci home alone me too
everyone did their jobs except I don't
know if it was the screen writer or the
director but whoever is responsible for
making this story like come full circle
didn't do their job you know what this
particular story in this part of history
is definitely interesting but I don't
know if the story of the Irish man is a
story worth telling yeah but it and it's
like this it's about the story of the
Irish man yet the story worth telling is
Jimmy Hoffa right and that's the story
being told
orange you don't realize that until two
and a half hours in or just like the
Bufalino crime family I'm sure they
wouldn't make just an interesting an
hour and a half movie yeah the booths
the most movie vibe at 11:00 we're
seizing 11:00 a little bit 11:00 maybe
wait I got it justice for Gabrielle
Union and Julia and how should she
choose to accept it also um I just wish
that like people would tapping so
blinded by the fact that Martin Scorsese
made a movie and talked openly about the
fact that it kind of stunk okay yeah and
I want a sequel called boozy lads by
Marty the Vampire Slayer
movie the mobs just laying um and you
know what the fact that it was long
didn't bother me because I watched Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood it was so long
and I didn't love it until the the last
10 minutes made the whole movie worth
watching that it happened with the
Irishman I would have gotten in and I
think when we broke for dinner and we
were like
this next hours about to have a half an
hour of cinema we've ever seen and it
wasn't it's just met and you know it
because it's on Netflix like watch it
and we can all talk about it you
shouldn't not see it and you know what
the story is interesting which is so
crazy it's like even a boring two hours
of mob stuff is interesting what did you
find that only true story all that stuff
that JFK and the master like krob is
Bobby Kennedy like the craziness was so
crazy so it was it was all there but
then it just they didn't land the plane
it fell flat so that was our thought on
it but we watch The Lion King and I'm so
upset that I didn't watch it sooner
because I have planned on seeing it in
theaters and Ben saw it he was like
Claudia it was horrible like it was so
realistic like you it was just like a
dirty jungle with like animals who
looked too realistic like it didn't make
sense they did it too well and I don't
say like I felt that call Mike I
definitely agree it said that on the
show what are they gonna do talking
animals like is this Eliza Thornberry
National Geographic but the animals talk
I don't understand it was literally the
most stunning movie I've ever seen was a
masterpiece it was a masterpiece this
soundtrack was phenomenal I love that
they change the classics too much yeah
and and then Zack had seen and he didn't
love it either which is why I didn't see
and I was like wait what didn't you like
about it he was like it's the same as
the original nothing changed I was like
why that's a [ __ ] boy I hate when
remakes take creative changes well
obviously it was it was as perfect as
Beauty and the Beast agreed we're like
everything on it so stunning they had
the best of the best like it was
incredible it was so beautiful all you
have to do is watch the opening scene
and you're hooked
the opening scene was stunning I thought
the voices were amazing I thought that
um childish gambino did an amazing job
as older Simba who ever played Mufasa
was shook worthy also scar scar was um
John James Jimmy a bag
Chiwetel Ejiofor Oh General James his
transoral jokes that is I believe in
fossa he played the original Mufasa - oh
he did yes so he was just like I thought
the voices were incredible I thought
that the dynamic you have Seth Rogen
ability Eichner was its tariff obviously
they stole the show for me it was Seth
Rogen because I was watching for so long
I'm like I know this voice who is this
voice and then when you told me it was
Seth Rogen it was like knowing it was
Seth Rogen didn't ruin it right
and it was and him and Billy Eichner
were perfection one of the hyenas with
those hyenas the dogs were like the
villainess was someone and it was
bothering like I can't watch animated
movies as an adult because all I do is
try and figure out who the voices are
and it was pissing me off did I so much
that I just went on ing be and he was
Kim Peele guy Michael key kyun whatever
salmon I like when I recognized the
voice but I can't put my finger on him
like okay
which is why Beyonce as Nala yes it was
so distracting it's my fiance can we see
her
it's my only hot take on the film was
that I didn't live for Beyonce being an
animated voice I think she's far too
famous because she's not a lion she's a
superstar like you can't be queen of the
jungle right it was just it wasn't
believable at all her voice is way too
recognizable I thought she did a
beautiful job on the soundtrack and she
should have been involved with the film
anyway but I liked her voice like even I
I know who a child is can be no it's
like I wouldn't recognize his voice out
of a lineup like yeah but I watch all
seasons of community and still like
Donald Glover who evaded me right so I
think that it was not the right fit
that's high only critiqued oh not come
for me beehive like not only because
she's too good it's really the critique
like a great voice is too recognizable
and now it's like Oh Beyonce seer like
can we see her can she dance for us like
right you know yeah can we get like a
totally but overall it was incredible
everyone should see it and like the
technology to CGI and then I can't
believe I ever doubted Disney like
disappointed and the talking animals was
not weird at all no and it was so
stunning it was so stunned that I had
looked tears in my eyes during the first
circle of life when they put the red and
he'll say but he's Theo oh that's what I
was thinking the whole time like it was
just it was beautiful and I loved that
everything is CGI like now after Lion
King like not no movie in Hollywood has
any excuse for using a real animal as
entertainment like it's so cruel you CGI
that [ __ ] if it's lying he could do an
entire film with CGI animals you can get
Marley and me to be a fake dog okay no
it wouldn't be as powerful no it would
you wouldn't know that's your power
you wouldn't know such a powerful film
Marley me yes I never saw you
oh my god it's too sexy and watch things
about guys like whales and I had no
horse in this race did you watch the
Netflix series dog dogs oh my god we
watched one episode I was in it was like
a happy thing it was about these like
really special dogs who are trained to
help kids with seizures I just it was it
was like a happy thing I was just
hysterical II crying like I cannot watch
cinema or anything with dogs like it
makes me really sad um also I went to
dinner last night and we were all
talking about the Irishman with Ben's
family and Ben sister actually told me
that there's a like a BuzzFeed or
something that shows you how to watch
the Irishmen as a series like 30 minutes
here 30 min like where to stop it and
end it and actually thought that was
kind of an interesting maybe it would've
been better as things in would've been
like a docu-series right like Chernobyl
the greatest series ever right speaking
of greatest series I'm watching the
crown right now I think I'm on like
Episode six or seven I watched it all
day yesterday and it's just so good even
though it's like so slow and so boring
and it's like I would never suggest
anyone watch it but once you're in if
you are into it it's just so good I'm
you know it they switch to the cast now
goodbye Claire Foy hello Olivia Colman
and it's they're really doing a great
job and like from the back it's still
Queenie bags like it's crazy
so this Cruise and like from the side
sometimes I see both of them they've
done a really good job um I want to
recap all the TV from last night but I
have to tell you the absolute craziest
thing that happened to me because like I
said it was your dinner last night
and I was walking into my do your makeup
for it yeah it's on IG to here anyway we
could see what how you did your makeup
girl with a job Instagram I do TV they
may be put up in two parts IG TV being
15 minutes max are you kidding yeah that
was like a Ricky mistake on your part
like everyone else does everyone know
that everyone's already experienced that
like learning that I've never operated a
GTV I felt like a grandma trotting humor
showing your age I'm sorry but I was it
was raining like crazy we were running
from the building to the uber and my
phone fell out of my pocket into the
rain into the street right on top of a
like a sewage great that has holes in it
my phone was literally not only interest
from being crack but interest between
from falling into the duty right that's
disgusting it's disgusting and it didn't
crack majorly I used to not carry a
phone case and I cannot believe how
reckless I was now I use a case to fight
case which it's like waterproof it's
perfect and obviously didn't crack which
was a wonderful thing from and they're
so freaking cute quesa Phi is the
world's slimmest no protective phone
case with tons of
classic designs stylish collaborations
and the ability to create your own
custom case case defy lets you keep your
phone safe without sacrificing style
like why do you have to have a big bulky
brick as a phone if you just don't want
to crack every time you drop it down a
subway grate they have a two-layer GTECH
material construction and have passed a
drop test from a height of 6.6 feet they
offer military-grade phone protection
with thousands of designs to choose from
you'll be able to find the perfect case
for your aesthetic case de by often
collaborates with artists and designers
past collaborations include sailor on
Pokemon Sarah Jessica Parker DHL Wonder
Woman and Rolling Stones they also
recently did a Lisa Frank collaboration
and it is cleany as a house so freakin
cute they let you have the best of both
worlds military grade at drop protection
and a stylish phone case you'll actually
want to show off there's no need for a
bulky phone case that turns your phone
into an ugly brick taste of my cases are
sleek and chic as your actual phone they
have thousands of designs to choose from
they have done awesome collaborations
with artists and designers then there's
also the best collaboration ever yours
you can create custom cases with your
favorite colors and texts of course they
really do protect your phone they will
keep your phone safe and stylish through
drops at more than six feet celebrities
like Kylie Jenner and are obsessed you
know this is a phone case you can show
off on your Instagram feed totally you
know more my favorite part about ki
safai is because we were just talking
about how we want to get new phones but
then like it's such a process to have a
new phone you have to get a new case and
everything but like hey safai you could
have a new phone case so quickly and an
actually cute one right that's the hard
thing like Ben's dad has like this
old-school [ __ ] like it's an it is
the biggest phone case I've ever seen
and it has like this film on it and
every time he goes to use his phone it's
like so sad because it doesn't work I'm
like Bruce that's a gift go to Kate's to
fight calm slash toast today to get 20%
off your new favorite phone case that's
case two five.com slash toast that's 20%
off your case tip I purchase CAS e TI FY
dot-com slash toast for 20% off your
taste if I purchase sign on and don't
break your phone sign and feel free to
drop your phone yeah and it soo it feel
free to take a mirror selfie because
your case in my case will be so cute
yeah okay let's recap real Keeping Up
with the Kardashians yes new episode was
a sign I also caught up on the previous
week's episode of the whole kandi drama
it was really funny how
at the like Courtney was obviously being
insane but at the end of the episode Kim
was like there's way too much candy here
yeah and actually was the perfect
episode because it was like Kim got her
way but then she also like everyone
admitted they were wrong but everyone
was right and wrong and like it was a
very cute sisterly way to end it a theme
through this throughout this season of
Kardashian's is Kourtney and Kim
fighting and then like them both calling
on Khloe and you know what kind of
bothers me is that Khloe doesn't take a
side and they feel like since they both
kind of value Khloe so much they both
call her every time they fight if she
would take a side it would actually I
think be helpful yeah because then the
person be like Oh Khloe thinks this way
I'm wrong and she doesn't take sides
like I just want her she does in favor
Kim or favor Kourtney like I want to
know what she actually thinks she just
said something like everyone's calling
me it's annoying like no what's your
opinion no totally also what's weird is
like in every episode there's always
this tension between Kim and Kourtney
they have like the least in common like
they're a just class the most they
totally different sets of values right
but then in real life they're always
together they were together for
Thanksgiving with the kids in Japan I
think it's the kids that Kourtney was
the only one in the Kanye music video
for clothes on Sunday with her kids yeah
and yeah I'm sure it's the kids thing
but it's like they actually I think
spend the most time together that's so
interesting they couldn't be more
different but you're right I just think
the fact that they have they both have
the most amount of kids and they're the
closest in age like North and Penelope
that must be it but that is weird
you know so they obviously I mean they
obviously get along and it's like even
when we fight as sisters like we're
sisters ya know they just happen to be
fighting on like one of the biggest
platforms in the world that's the
difference
yeah the subplot of Khloe and her OCD
was so stupid and then honestly like
them having that food fight was in this
climate like you cannot be so wasteful I
was really getting upset I'm like that
pasta like I would have eaten that whole
thing yeah it was really stupid yeah
that was that was like things I used to
do back in the day and they still like
do stuff like that even with this this
week's episode like the dogs for Chloe
I really wished she had kept one because
they were so beautiful and I really
think it would add so much like value to
her life and it's never a good time for
a dog no but you know what I did think
that whole thing was weird because um
they already get like a lot of [ __ ] they
have like so many dogs like coming and
going like whatever happens to like half
the dogs that they talk about or post
pictures of and like then they kind of
just like quietly disappear there is
like a lot of weird like fodder around
there
and I just thought that was like a weird
thing for them to include like getting
three dogs than like getting them up
like it was just a little bit like at
the dogs anything they probably probably
just bar like took them for the day and
then they Chloe said she found homes for
them no she didn't say she thought home
for them
she said that they have homes so I'm
sure they gave them back to the breeder
and then she said that she did research
she knows that they're gonna be in good
she probably did the research about
where they went and also just said that
so people wouldn't talk about it yeah I
don't I don't think they should that
Kris ever like signed for the dogs and
then had to yeah you know she took
borrow the dogs also did hurt some of
the dog is like cute but to get them
three isn't it like if she had gotten
her lunch you might have had a chance I
know and that whole Gabbana thing was so
sad they're like I do feel like she
needs a new job in her life no I totally
agree and then also I know people were
saying like where's Norman like highly
strong but Kylie stood her dogs all the
time and then peanut she's all like dog
services no because your dogs were too
skinny so it's like I'm not gonna [ __ ]
pose many people called like the Humane
Society the come and check on her house
which was so [ __ ] up which was so
crazy cuz her dogs are skinny but those
are skinny dogs ya know that was
incredibly sometimes actually people
don't share things with us because we
can't have nice things
right so I think she just stopped
posting them not that she like these
days appeared she loves it were kids so
she was posing them now she has a kid so
she post a kid right um I was literally
sobbing I don't think I've ever seen
like Kim really like cry like that like
Kourtney cries all the time but I don't
think I've ever really seen Kim like
have so much empathy yes really like
Sakura she's the queen like she can't
have an emotion a lot of the time
because she can't ruin her makeup even
when Alice Marie Johnson got out of jail
she was in the middle of a shoot she
could not shoot that I'm gonna cry I
like never saw them just like be so like
I don't even think they remembered they
were on camera in that moment it was so
sad and it was just kind of full circle
how when they first met that woman she
didn't say my daughter hazel passed away
she just said oh Kylie came and visited
that was so cute and they obviously
didn't realize that hazel was no longer
with us and then like when that woman
got up there and she's saying then he
still went into her mission I was like
that's great and then she was like oh
and then two years later I was like
literally sobbing and like watching them
cry made me cry it was so sad and like
[ __ ] clean it up bowing oh what the
[ __ ] is that and then all the kids in
the same community to all be like
getting cancer is [ __ ] weird and I
can't believe more people weren't
talking about getting sick it's so
[ __ ] up and like Kim tweeted last
night that nothing's been done to start
the cleanup and so like and by the way
senator
what's good is this daddy been like oh
god the way he's like a local like
politician like I don't think there's
much that you can do like this needs to
be taken to a higher level yeah I mean
he's a senator like but yes it it
definitely needs to be taken to a higher
level and a do you think last night's
episode was that platform that they
needed like they were tweeting about it
before but you know that's not people a
lot of people tweet a lot of things
right I think hopefully last night's
episode like shines a bigger light on it
and like Boeing and the feds like get
your [ __ ] together always always like
being a corrupt we gotta talk to TBG
about that like he old knows all about
Boeing and like why is a plane company
like responsible for this nuclear plant
because they were doing research and
they was toxic
I don't know and like why are you doing
research like in it anyway kids live
like do it in the desert it's so weird
yeah area 51 and now watching
Kardashians through the lens that
Courtney is gonna be taking a step back
it's like so making me excited because
she really burst the show yeah she
really does yeah Kim is like it's just
everything to me and Kylie planning
Khloe's birthday party she did such a
good job that was very funny how they
talk about Kylie's like yeah we talked
about Kylie's card you know but it's
like to get Kylie to plant a pirate
party if you it's like Bill act like
they're like poor and it's like oh you
got a Kylie party like it's like so
different nobody it is I think it's just
because she's so creative um like any of
them can like plan a party but like what
she did for like stormy world for
Stormy's birthday like so they did
Candyland they never thought of doing
Northland no you know so I I do think
like Chloe really deserved it I loved
her trip to Mohegan Sun that's what I
was gonna say that was so much fun like
that's just like what being famous
should be like 100% your kid you don't
worry about him he's with she's with the
dad very normal you just take a quick
24-hour trip on a private jet get [ __ ]
up with the friends you have so much fun
make a ton of cash and the flyback of
the brand like make a music video in
your hotel room that was so funny that
looked so much fun Chloe really is like
the one I feel like I would relate to
the most
I'm like oh like where she's at in her
life level like she has it all yeah she
got the kid the man Tristan wants her
she got to ring she had the ring and the
bracelet necklace and now she's just
like out here partying that looked like
so much fun it was a great ad for
Mohegan Sun I kind of want to go know
and like the vistas at Mohegan Sun who
knew when Khadijah was like this is what
like comes up on your Apple TV no I knew
exactly what she was talking
beautiful we gotta go to Mohegan Sun you
should do a show there totally it's like
very similar to Fox votes actually love
doing Foxwoods
yeah but the views at Foxwoods were not
it no because there were none um I'm
gonna quickly recap real how some
atlanta even though you don't watch this
is just my plate another week to tell
you that it's a greatest franchise I
enjoy listening to your recaps um so
Cynthia Bailey held her annual Bailey BQ
which is like not even a good name like
she thinks it's so funny like Bailey Q
Bailey Q it's not a good name like she
could have come up something better it's
just a barbecue everybody got oh it
always ends up being a che diae
something always happens um I'm just
like really starting to like submit my
feelings for certain Housewives and like
harder than ever I stand Porsha like I
just think she literally put this
franchise on her back for so many
seasons but now she's reaping the
rewards up because she's a mom and like
she doesn't want to film as much and she
just does it on her own time she brings
her kid wherever the [ __ ] she wants oh
you see she there we engaged she was on
my travels I bus and she looked at
Stough snatch um she's reengaged to
Dennis and I'm actually okay with that
like I don't think he's a bad guy per se
I just think it was like really [ __ ]
up to not only cheap like to cheat when
she was pregnant 100% which reminds me
what are your thoughts on like Chloe and
Tristan I don't I I literally don't get
what if they got back together
great what if they didn't great okay my
life goes on and I don't even think
twice about it um but was really
interesting was that the Bailey Q like
Cynthia was trying to make it like
everyone eats see it's so late like she
was just kind of being like a drug
pusher you know what I mean like Tina
Fey and Mean Girls um and then Porsha
and Kenya both called me like we bring
babies and she said no she said no to
Kenya in Kenya was like pissed and then
Porsha called she was like very
matter-of-fact she liked Porsha can't
leave her kid like she's having some
sort between just like being postpartum
and also like what she's going through
with Dennis like she's very attached to
the baby she bother maybe to work she
went back to work she can't she can't
like maybe she's like I'll bring a nanny
but I just got a brand new nanny and I
don't want to leave her alone with the
kid like two days in like Kimmy all calm
and Cynthia finally she's like all right
yeah you can an itch called Kenya in
Kenya I was like no [ __ ] you I don't
ring baby anymore
so they all go and it's just very it's
explosive Eva and Kenya can not get
along and while I think Kenya is the
most petty [ __ ] alive like I
get on either side like yes the what may
be one of the worst house I was like I
just she's so fake and like she's so up
Cynthia's ask because she thinks it's
like I think her way to stay on the show
was like be relevant us to be friends
with Cynthia I'm like I just I don't
stand IVA like whatsoever I did like
last year and she really stood up for
herself but like it's not enough for me
to continue liking her like she's not
interesting beyond that so she left
because Kenya was like coming for her
but then Marlo came and I really feel
like Marlo in the Bravo universe is one
of the most interesting characters I
think she's been on every single season
of Atlanta and never once held a peach I
do think it's really unfair people are
so mean to her like whenever she gets
into a fight with someone everyone goes
solo they're like well you've never had
children so you don't know like that's
always what they they're like creating
you can't keep a man like things that
are so deeply personal and so rude like
she is so unfazed by it like she rolls
that [ __ ] off her back but she's in such
an interesting place in her life right
now where I feel like she should be a
housewife her sister has two kids
they're like teenagers and her sister is
I think like mentally ill and can no
longer take care of the kids so Marlo
literally opened her home to these two
teenagers they live with her now she's
like their mom aunt um I think they
still yeah I think still in real time
like they are living with her it's such
a crazy um like things she's going
through and actually make her a really
interesting TV and she gets to know
justice and I want justice for Marlo
that's it okay here for it sounds like
great Joe and once again like Cynthia
Bailey all she can do is talk about her
man and she is a woman who was defined
she's a Tinsley like she's a woman who's
defined by the men that she's with and
it's so boring wow that's a heightened
words yeah okay well I feel like we'll
talk about OC Dallas and New Jersey as
they come up this week yep but overall
for OC I'm just like so torn because I'm
team Kelly um but like she did you don't
get it mountain no you don't and also
like I really now more than ever Stan
Shannon storms like I think she is a
Phoenix who has risen from the ashes I'm
just saying by Ashley she's saying by
Ashley and she's such a good role model
for women like who it's so she's just so
relatable and she's never looked better
and I really like I believe in her and
like I want to fight for her but like
she is so loyal to Tamara that I think
to a point like it's almost a fault
and Kelly's wrong but so are they yeah
and they care always be that Kelly's
wrong
I feel great on that like she is always
victimized yeah and you know it's
hammers not telling 100% the truth
because yes she wasn't like she didn't
say that Kelly through her mom down the
stairs but she's been I should start all
season you just said it um New Jersey I
absolutely loved their dinner in Jamaica
but I didn't want Jersey so we talked
about it this week yes I already spoke
about Dallas and then Dallas I am team
lien on this one and just like team
Cameron for the week because she was so
funny she took his adits on the plane
and I couldn't remember anything she was
but when they like got off the plane I
love the way they edited that you
because honestly the guys ever feel
that's how I feel until you way to go
out there Travel day until you wake up
in the country like you're not human
yeah and I was like such a great
attitude about everything and it's a
very enjoyable trip to watch and so
Dallas's is like a phoenix rising from
the ashes it's getting there it's
getting it's sea legs love it okay well
thank you guys so much for watching the
morning Tessa millennium Morning Show it
is so good to be back thank you guys for
watching we are the morning shows we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so please
subscribe to us on YouTube give this
video a thumbs up leave a nice comment
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so that
Spotify iTunes stitcher public radio I
Heart Radio all the apps so head over
there subscribe leave us a five star
review about how stunning and smart we
are we love you guys so much our merch
drops of this Friday if you're looking
for more content and alarm1 o'clock
Friday a certain and pop in if you're
looking for more content there's a brand
new episode of Lauren Elizabeth's a
podcast mood with her so sexy ass
boyfriend Cameron fuller and sexy ass
best friend Kara Gregg Sulkin there's
also a new episode of a date night with
Raven and Adam where they have Cody and
Jessica from Big Brother on I do their
podcast Hilary the nicest yeah and she
was so pregnant when I met her so it's
just like a good like reality crossover
I think you guys will enjoy that and
always their episodes at our patreon
patron comm slash morning to get a
sister's episode all for that for the
[ __ ] that me take all your questions
and it's becoming an annual episode
exactly Iowa should add me pharyngitis
same year same interview different year
and it's really cute so head over there
if you're just missing us patreon.com
slash and morning toast we will see you
tomorrow
you